se le pide a gabi que reste menos 5 r al
cuadrado más 7 r menos dos de 13 r al
cuadrado menos 9 r 3 y abajo se muestra
lo que hizo ahora aquí podemos ver
entonces todos los pasos que ella hizo y
después dice en qué paso cometió gabe un
error queda claro que cometió un error
pues no se nos da la opción que indique
que no cometió un error entonces bueno
veamos qué pasó aquí lo primero que
queremos hacer es restar menos 5 r al
cuadrado más 7 rm 2 de 3 r al cuadrado
menos 9 r 3 y vemos que en el paso 1 lo
hizo bien aquí está restando menos 5 r
al cuadrado más 7 r menos dos de 13 r al
cuadrado menos 9 r más 3 entonces bueno
el paso el paso 1 está bien hecho veamos
el paso 12 entonces parece que va a
distribuir el signo negativo
el negativo de menos 5 r al cuadrado más
7 r
2 es el negativo de menos 5 r al
cuadrado es más 5 r al cuadrado bien el
negativo
+ 7 r al cuadrado es menos 7 r bien
hecho el negativo de menos 2 es 2
positivo entonces bien hecho así que
bueno el paso 2 está bien ejecutado
vamos ahora con el paso 3 entonces en el
paso 3 vemos que está agrupando términos
semejantes el término r al cuadrado lo
tiene este coeficiente el 3 y este
coeficiente también el 5 pero vemos que
aquí ella agrupó el 3 y el menos 9 eso
está mal porque estos no son términos
semejantes uno tiene la r al cuadrado y
el otro no entonces bueno el error está
aquí en el paso 3 de hecho también
cometió el mismo error con el término 5
r al cuadrado y menos 7 r porque bueno
uno tiene la r al cuadrado y el otro no
así que no son términos semejantes los
únicos que sí al grupo bien solo el 3 y
el 2 eso sí son términos semejantes
entonces bueno el error está en el paso
el error en el paso 4 lo que gaby a ser
razonable lo hace como si hubiera
agrupado términos semejantes entonces
bueno lo que ella hace es tres menos
nueve eso es menos seis entonces tenemos
menos seis r al cuadrado
5 - 7 es menos 2 menos 20 y 3 más 12 55
así que bueno lo que ella hizo ahí está
bien pero su tropiezo fue en el paso 3
pero de ahí en adelante lo que está
haciendo es razonable pero cometió un
error en el paso 3